As you've seen, graphs are great for
modelling connections between elements.
That's wonderful on its own, but graphs
are really powerful because they're so
easy to traverse based on connections.
Graph traversal is a lot
like tree traversal.
Again, a tree is just a specific
type of graph, so that makes sense.
We have two basic methods for traversal.
A depth first search, where we follow
one path as far as it'll go, and
a breadth first search, where we look
at all the nodes adjacent to one
before moving on to the next level.
These traversals
techniques often show up
bundled into more advanced
graph algorithms.
So make sure you understand
them before you move on.